kd was basically like listen it's going
to be a news story for two days
whether you go anywhere else or stay in
la and then people are going to move on
he was right
hello candace
wow
uh fresh from mexico oh you know
coffee is not a margarita but it'll do
oh my gosh we'll trade it out for marg's
next time uh here on the show so jealous
though what part of mexico so i went to
punta de meda flew into pbr
great time yeah yeah it's like it's like
paradise yeah do you always do vacation
after a season i try to do it after the
season um this season was a little
delayed just because i went straight
into nba um
but i try to get a little r r yeah
relaxation and my vacation is like i
don't do things
i'm not one of those like let's go climb
a mountain and hike and stuff like
vacation is like layla goes and plays in
the water with her cousins i sit on the
beach with a margarita yeah like it's
not like let's horts back ride no let's
go like atm being or atving whatever go
see like the zoo no yeah like we are
chilling and we're doing nothing well i
mean
you deserved a vacation you know fresh
off a championship
round of applause randomly plus um but i
need first things first whose idea was
it to bring the door to the parade
listen i
was like everyone else i showed up and
was just like why is there a door oh
i see what y'all did there yeah yeah
diana taurasi was here i see what y'all
did there yeah um
yeah our our fans are you know a little
putty so yeah i can deal with a little
bit of putty yeah i mean i like it it's
fun yeah yeah and then there were
halloween costumes there was a halloween
costume that won it was a person that
dressed up like dt
and then
her friend was the door
that's funny do you have photos can you
show me later i will okay pass them
along no i love it it's funny how
these things kind of get a mind of their
own everyone's talking about the door
bring door to parade and then the parade
comes and it actually is there i just
thought it was great and that's
something that everybody is going to
remember that you all caused her so many
fits
that she punched the door and then we
all got to look at it as you guys
celebrated uh your championship so i
love it congrats to you i haven't been
able to see you in person i tell you
congratulations and i know it means so
much because
one thing you talked a lot about is like
getting two
and that difference between one and two
it's like what does one championship
signify for you but what does two
championships signify for you it's
interesting because um
you know i've grown up in a household
where it's always like you do something
they're like well if you really are good
at it you could do it again
like it really solidifies it if you can
do it a second time
and um
that's kind of what it what it is you
know there's a lot of
especially in this world like you do
something one time it's like good great
cool could have been
an accident a mishap or
just luck and i don't think you get that
lucky twice so to be able to um
to win a championship and especially
in the fashion that we wanted this
season wasn't easy uh we were succeed we
had injuries we had up and down
everybody goes through that but
you know at the end of the day it was
great to win it with this group and
especially in the city of chicago do you
feel like there were doubts about like
you or your game when it was just one
i definitely feel like every athlete um
has doubts
it's interesting because i'm i'm on the
media side now yeah so i think
being in media has helped me as a
basketball player and being a basketball
player has helped me in media
and i think in
figuring out that balance of like what
do you really want to listen to because
i'm the type that like you tell me i
can't do something or you tell us we
suck or you pick us to lose i'm like bet
i'm excited yeah like please i want to
prove you wrong
um
and i think sometimes it gets hard when
you're expected to do it so i liked all
the criticism and
i like being called washed
because i think in the off season
sometimes you need that motivation on a
random saturday in january to prepare
for a season that's in april
and i think i you know i lined all that
up and
you know pushed through can you give me
some examples of how being in the media
has helped you i know you touched on it
a bit but can you elaborate on that a
bit more
i
really feel as though as athletes um
we really don't get upset when somebody
speaks about our game but to me i try to
stay away from character and personality
and things like that because i think
there's a lot that we don't know
and i think just being in media and
understanding that it's such a hard job
to
figure out that line to walk
but then also being an athlete and
understanding that it's the media's job
to criticize
and to look at your game i mean that's
literally what i get paid to do right
out of season's job is to talk about
people's games both positive and
negative and um
you know i just
try to not make it personal and i think
as a player i understand as long as it's
not personal you know and i think
there's some people you have people that
you cheer for like i'm it's no secret
i'm a bulls fan okay so i cheer for the
bulls yeah and i am a steph curry and a
kevin durant fan those are my two
players that i love watching and i
i do see the positive in there yeah but
it's hard in media to not let that carry
over when you're criticizing someone so
when you're constantly and i think
sometimes within women's basketball i
have some critics that like to
constantly criticize me which is great
when i need to be criticized but there's
sometimes when you you know you want a
good job too yeah totally especially if
you you're almost feeling like it feels
targeted in some ways so you said you
know basketball players don't mind when
someone talks about their game but it's
when it talks about their character i
think it's also when they talk about
legacy
i think athletes take that so incredibly
personal when you aren't speaking about
their legacy in the way that they view
themselves would you agree with that
you know when we talk about legacy while
somebody is still building their legacy
i think it's interesting because it's
like jumping in the book you know and
saying that
this book is terrible but it hasn't even
reached
the story that's trying to tell yet
and i think that that's what we do a lot
of times we're always doing hot takes of
well this person is terrible this person
like i'll give chris paul as an example
because i feel like i relate to him as
well you know they were saying that he
couldn't play and he's not a good leader
when he was in houston and then all of a
sudden in okc it was like oh my gosh
he's the best leader and now in phoenix
oh my gosh so sometimes it's you know
it's the situation in the per person
meeting that perfect storm
and um you know i think definitely a
situation does determine sometimes like
how things are and it tells your story
but when you start talking about legacy
when you still have time left like
imagine if chris paul's career would
have ended in houston yep but he's still
that same person he's still that same
player but it's just a different you
know opportunity and so for me i'm like
let's talk about legacy when it's all
said and done yeah because i think then
we remember truly like overall what an
athlete has done for the game yeah
because sports like with everything you
you have to give time time
and everything depends on where you
start a story where you end the story
you know if someone was talking about
your career they might if they ended it
before you got that first championship
the story is she can't do it
then you get the championship and i'm
like okay she got one but now you go
back home it was like a movie
you go back home you win the
championship and now this legacy even
though it is still being written has a
completely different meaning and i don't
know if we give
athletes or people really that grace to
grow and understand themselves their
situation and i think fans in general
don't understand how situational
athletes and athletics is in general
like everything is about the team you're
on what you're around and we take like
athletes take it so personally because
you're like well you're not seeing the
full picture you're seeing it so
casually and not in a way that that
fully tells the entire story so i think
i think that's a that's a really really
good way to put it but i know you asked
this all the time but are you still
writing the legacy how much time do we
have left of candice in the wnba it's a
very interesting question um to me
personally i have a group of friends and
family that i said very early in my
career that if i don't recognize that
it's time for me to hang it up
then they need to gently tell me that
it's time to hang it up i don't want to
cheat the game um a game that has given
me so many opportunities so many
experiences so many relationships i will
never cheat the game of basketball um
and i think i'll know you know i'll know
when it's time and it's not going to be
during the season it's not going to be
it's going to be when i can't adequately
prepare for the season i can't
adequately get myself out of bed and
guess what listen
these youngins like i had a rookie on my
team that was like laughing at me like
oh you know like your speed and
quickness and whatever is rated low and
all this stuff i'm like you didn't
understand i used to have wheels okay i
used to be able to get up and down the
court and y'all remembering this version
and it's not fun when people remem
remember you in this version
and so i think you know
when i'm competitive so when it stops
being fun being able to like
beat that you know because i think
there's competing and there's being able
to like but like i don't want to compete
like i want to be able to dominate and
it might not be all the time but just
like okay let me turn this on absolutely
you know and when i when when that when
that switch don't turn over all the way
it starts sputtering in the off season i
don't know well i read something you
said i judge it based on how i'm feeling
how are you feeling i'm feeling good i
think this year was challenging just
with injuries and realizing that like at
35 an ankle injury that i probably would
have recovered from um a lot quicker and
maybe maybe not a lot quicker but it
wouldn't have had a lingering impact
um
i think i realized that and i definitely
want to end the game
walking away from it on two feet i don't
want to crawl i don't want to roll i
don't want to be carried i want to end
it
walking away from it and i want to be
able to play with my daughter i want to
be able to be able to play with my kids
and you know it's not fun losing to your
kids like i'm not going to play
basketball and
you know ayla's coming layla is coming
and i'm like
i can't it's too early for me to not
play her right so i'm like i still have
to be able to do a little something yeah
because i mean you know i was watching a
bunch of interviews reading bunch of
articles and 2018 there was a video
someone asked you this and you said i'm
in three four more years but it's funny
because that's
we're here oh it's now yeah that's now
we're reaching that uh we're reaching
that point yeah for sure and i think um
especially after this year and as
mentally taxing and physically taxing as
this year is i think it's best to take
some time and um you know obviously the
grind of everything off the court as
well
you know kind of carries over i'm i'm
fortunate enough to be to have another
job that i love yeah and um
you know to be able to kind of
be doing that alongside playing which is
the number one job you know i feel very
fortunate to be able to do that yeah and
we love having you you're the best i
always like hey you guys she is the best
analyst so let's let's put some respect
on it so obviously you know you haven't
decided what the future looks like yet
but how many times in your career have
you thought about retiring girl listen
2018 was
2018 was tough yeah for me and i think
it was more so mentally because
you know i think it's like you pour so
much
you know into things 2019
really difficult um and it was kind of
like those two seasons that were really
hard um
and when it's
not as much joy as it is just a grind
you start questioning you know
what you're doing it for and
you know you speak of athletes and i
think we're super fortunate to be able
to do what we do but it is a job
you know and i think if
i'm not complaining because i think this
is why i love being an athlete there are
fans and there are fans that are
criticizing you but it's like imagine
sitting at your desk and doing something
wrong or not working out and somebody
being like ah
yeah
like you got called into the boss's
office like it's just
it's tough and it's taxing and you go
through ups and downs um
but i just remember talking to my dad
and my mom and then just being like
you're built for this like
you do things that people don't expect
to be able to be done and so sh they're
like if anybody's gonna be able to
bounce back from this it's you
and i think it's just it's one of those
things where it's like when don't you
bounce but like when is it
enough to just bounce
right
when is it enough to just be like all
right you know and um
you know when that time comes then i'll
i'll know yeah so when you talk about
2018 2019 what specifically brought you
back
i love basketball
basketball has been my
solace my inspiration
um
it was my first love
you know and um
i think the amount of sacrifices and
just
you think you've done i've been playing
competitive basketball since i was 13
years old
i am now 35. so it's almost been
almost 20 years of competitive
basketball that's not even the yba or
like whatever i've been playing that
since i was five right competitive
basketball
and so it's just that love for the game
you know and i think sometimes we have
to remember that like child-like
excitement that we used to get when we
pull up after eating mcdonald's and go
play five aau games and then
you know get back home and then go out
in the driveway and play again
you know and so i just think that that
excitement brought me back to the game
okay
and and i think that's beautiful and we
now have this
storybook tale of you winning going home
and winning a championship i want to
talk about your time in l.a
if you're talking about your time with
the la sparks right tell me how you
would describe the beginning tell me how
you described the middle and how you
would describe the end
the beginning was filled
with this
first season
um
where i had this like
attitude like i would call that almost
like my tweens
where you know like tweens think they
know everything yeah but then like let
them be right one time and then they
really know everything
that's how my first rookie year was like
i look at lisa leslie and delisha milton
all the time and i call lisa smooth and
i'm like man i don't know how you dealt
with me at that age yeah you know
because there's just this 22 year old
that thinks she knows everything but
doesn't but then has a little success
you know um
and then that off season when i found
out i was pregnant with my daughter
you know going through and maneuvering
that so it was just like the newness the
you know and played pregnant by the way
yeah and um and to be able to have layla
at that age i think it was the best
thing that could have happened after
that rookie and mvp season was because
it just
it brought me back down to reality of
what's important and i don't know if i
would have made it through the middle
part and the ending of my la career if i
hadn't had layla
because i think for so long for those
first five or six years in la everything
was basketball
basketball basketball i gotta get back
to basketball you know i played eight
weeks after i had her i had to get back
i had to play i had to you know i had to
continue my career we lost it was like
my best friend justine would come over
we'd get snacks and tequila and lay in
bed for four days you know like
lost like we literally mourned losses
um
especially
literally and so that's what she
whispered to me we won in chicago she
was like remember we used to mourn
losses and she's like now look at us you
know
so i think it's um that was the
beginning the middle but the middle part
i was i got through it with layla you
know like layla was always there she was
always watching and then i think that's
towards the end like that's how i would
describe it as well is the fact that
you know la became home
you know and i think there was a lot of
loyalty and a
a lot of feelings of it becoming home
you know so it was really difficult for
me to leave because it was like i was
leaving home i was going home
but i was leaving a home that i had
established and that's all my my
daughter knew yeah
leaving la though
what emotion did you feel towards
the sparks
so here's the thing um
i think sometimes
the way i feel
or the way i felt about leaving la
you know when you
and this is something pat summitt would
always talk about you know when
you empower your your players or you
empower somebody and they feel ownership
for something and that's the most
valuable thing that you can possess is
ownership over something like
you know
you own this or you own that or you you
know you almost own that and i felt like
it was kind of like i was
throwing the keys to my car to some you
know so i think leaving la was so hard
because it was like neca and myself were
the longest tenured sparks we spent so
much time building that
you know what i mean and refining it and
like being there through the tough times
and
having to deal with losses and injuries
and
just
everything yeah and so i felt like it
was like
i was kind of signing over that
ownership it was your baby's giving it
yeah like i was giving it away and um i
think that was the the toughest thing
for me to grasp is like
the city the people
yeah the organization's amazing but i'm
saying like the people the faces behind
that is what was so difficult and of
course neca i mean you know i called and
told her and talked to her and
it's difficult because
you know we really have grown together
and um
you know it was really difficult to say
goodbye but it was something i knew i
needed to do yeah so i really respect
her for being happy for me yeah and
making this jump and you know
and making that decision i love neca and
schnee there's just the sisters they're
great um
there was a bit of drama or at least
perceived drama but you and derek fisher
what is your relationship with derek
fisher now what was it then were people
making too much of it
because i've never once heard you
discuss it listen um
[Music]
i think
there were definitely things that we
didn't see eye to eye on
i'm a firm believer and this is why just
in my work in media with analyzing and
being an mba analyst this is similar to
why i
don't know what's going on with ben
simmons and i can't speak of it is
because i think
it's
everybody's responsibility to keep
things in-house
and i think just from
an example i think my relationship with
derrick fisher grew me as an individual
and as a person do i want to go through
the bumps and bruises and everything
that we've gone through
as an organization and whole not even
just between him and i
but i've also learned that
there is a value in picking yourself and
choosing you and sometimes dynamics
don't work
and it's okay
you know um
and i think that
that was something that
i value is that i don't think we let a
lot of the stuff spill over in terms of
who said what or what was you know
really going on and i think that that's
the value that i've had with the sparks
this is like we kept the locker room the
locker room
it didn't carry over to where the
coaches were
it didn't there wasn't you know there
was none of that and so i think for me
personally i grew
um after 2019 especially being able to
come back and to play for the sparks and
to finish my contract i didn't quit and
i think that's the biggest thing that's
the biggest misconception i didn't quit
like my contract was up i stayed my
tenure
i was a free agent and could choose
where i wanted to go and so i made a
choice of where i best thought i would
be happy and fit and that was with the
chicago sky yeah
i had a um i had a college professor
once who was talking to me about the
push versus the pool like if i was
talking about jobs where i wanted to go
he's like i want you to measure do you
make your decisions based on being
pushed out of something or being pulled
to something like that so when you think
about
sparks
and then now going to chicago sky do you
feel like you are motivated by the push
or the pull that's a really good i love
that analogy because i feel like um
i feel like bosses push and leaders pull
and so
i think that's an amazing analogy
because i use that where like leaders
get where they want the team to go and
pull you there um
that's an internet i like that yeah
taylor you're dropping knowledge
um
honestly
i don't think that i was pushed out of
la by any means um and i had whole heart
whole-hearted intention like it was
never a time where
you know at that moment because my
brother was on the team with cleveland
with lebron when he we all looked at his
face and we knew that was probably the
last time you put on a cleveland jersey
there was never any moment like that
like it wasn't like i pulled up to
staple center in 2019 and was like yup
this is the last time i'm playing here
or like in 2020 in the bubble like yup
it's the last time i'm gonna wear this
jersey like
no it just happened over
the course of the off season
i didn't really even start thinking
about it being a possibility until
january i remember i called chelsea gray
and was like listen
it's 70 30 i'm going back to la 30
chance i'm going to chicago and then by
mid
january to end of january it was like
it's 60 40
you know and then it just kept and then
we i had a meeting with james during the
you know the free agency period and
then it was just my family and just
sitting on it so i don't think i was
pushed out of la and i didn't have any
intention after the last game of just
being done yeah but it was one of those
things that
i realized my fit
and i do realize that like sloot
alley
i
diamond like they all wanted me to be
there yeah i mean they were sending you
food was it illuminati was giordano's
what was it yeah okay
he's getting ready hey hey
um but yeah i think it was one of those
things where it was
you know it was one of those things
where it just kind of fell into place i
slept on it i'm one of those like let me
sleep on it for three days totally slept
on it for three days talked to layla
about it she was like but i'm wearing a
sparks jersey when y'all play the sparks
i'm like whatever you want to do late
whatever yeah did she
you know she wasn't at the game because
i was hurt okay but yeah she probably
will this year yeah so i know when you
were making that decision you called a
couple people i think you called kd
you called d wade
who am i missing that we wouldn't i mean
i talked to my brothers as well
okay what was the advice kevin gave you
that dwayne gave you that your brothers
gave you
kd was basically like listen it's going
to be a news story for two days
whether you go anywhere else or stay in
la and then people are going to move on
and then from there the scrutiny then it
switches to can you win or can you not
yep
he was right he literally it was hands
down like
and
he's like so if you're worried about
making your decision based off of other
people like this needs to be a decision
that you make and dude was the same
thing dude was just like listen
it is great to play at home but you have
to make sure that you're doing this
you know this is what you want to do you
make the decision that you want to make
and um
they were like you'll know
and i think i did you know and
especially after speaking with my
brother and my family and
it was just amazing to finally have that
weight and i think when i once i said it
and it was out there
it was one of those things where it was
tough
but
you know everybody was pretty much happy
for me that i i chose myself yeah that i
was able to choose what would make me
happy and not make the decision based
off of how it was going to impact you
know everybody else i also think people
like underestimate
the the fact that a lot of people don't
choose themselves a lot just in every
day a lot of times yeah i would say
people tend to choose others or other
things before they choose themselves so
there's a lot of power in saying well
this is the thing that's going to make
me happy and what i want to do and what
is going to be best for me and my family
or whatever the case may be so i would
commend you for really just deciding to
choose you but taylor i think the
biggest thing is
and i do want to go on and i know it
looks great because we won but when we
were like i think we were eight and
eight in the middle of the season i
i knew i made the right choice
regardless of the outcome even when it
was down yeah and i think going in
everybody's championship championship we
could possibly not win a championship
and that's fine i mean obviously i'm
competitive i want to win but that's not
going to make me
think rethink my choice
you know
i'm obviously going to step on the court
and try to win a championship but at the
end of the day i think people look at
results too much
like
you know and and i think at some point i
would really would be still sitting here
like i think i made the right decision
yeah because you lived you made that
choice and you lived in that choice yes
you said you think people look at
results too much what do you think they
should be focused on instead
here's my thing
we look at giannis as this mvp which he
is a greek freak but mvp
freak of nature unbelievable player this
year like to hear the commentator speak
about giannis this year
if we rewind to last year
he's putting up similar numbers actually
less
less numbers than this year this year
but they speak about him in such a way
that is so different because he won now
let's go back katie's foot is not on the
line the three-point line
that much right go back the greek freak
the greek freaks knee
that i was for sure
that it was done
comes back plays no damage no structural
damage then he's able to put up a
50-point
i mean almost triple like yeah it's
unbelievable what he's able and possible
to show but what if those didn't happen
so it's like now we're so results-driven
when it was it was in him all along
so i think sometimes
like i said about legacy you just have
to let it play out and then the cream
rhymes rises to the top you know and
it's like we always try to have these
hot takes and he's like well this year
he's not as good or whatever and it's
like guess what sometimes you just need
to reload like it's just about reloading
and like bouncing back or figuring it
out
um
and so i think that's my that's my thing
yes
sometimes results
were so focused on results which yeah
like winning six championships or
winning four winning three like it's
very special but sometimes the way we
talk about players based off of the
organization has to be right the coaches
have to be right the play like this
isn't technically not out there playing
tennis
[Music]
you know what i mean like you got to be
loyal but not too loyal because then you
might not be respected because you're
losing
so it's just like it's one of those
things where it's like just a bunch of
public that just kind of becomes talking
about like sometimes you can't focus on
just the results yeah
this task force doesn't officially exist
which leaves us on our own
two jerks and costumes and a couple of
rejects
it's like a real team out there
[Applause]
well i mean i do want to talk about
something that i guess maybe has to do
with legacy if you counted is that it
was a bit of controversy online
um this whole goat
vote
um so if anybody doesn't know the wnba
put out something where fans could vote
for a goat
and diana taurasi ended up winning that
did you have any feelings toward that
vote
well i think honestly
and especially the way that we're
judging i mean i've played with diana
diana is a hell of a player um
and
just in terms of the amount of buckets
that she's gotten over the course of her
career a lot of them has have been
against la sparks
and you know i mean the fans voted so
i mean you gotta you gotta respect the
vote but i think that we talk about i
mean in the words of isaiah thomas
criteria like what is the criteria of
what is what is the criteria and i think
we face that this year for my vote for
nba 75. it was very difficult what is
the criteria what are we basing this on
are we basing this on like just
overallness buckets are we basing this
on rebounds are we basing like
points just like playoffs what do we
what are we basing this on so i think
that was the question that you're never
going to have a sure answer and so
there's going to be a lot of barber
shops and things like that talk about
this and that's what you want well i
think the issue some people had with it
is even though the fans were voting it
felt like a wnba endorsed
thing like it was okay that means that
this person
is the go and i was kind of okay well
why are we voting again what is the
criteria but is that because when when i
was watching more videos of you i saw
this video or someone kind of said to
you okay do you feel like you're the
goat and you're like i'm gonna let you
guys decide
and then when that happened and people
ended up picking diana
did you were you like okay i wish there
was me i don't care about this vote like
what is your reaction to seeing the
actual listen if you're not a competitor
and you don't want to be the best like
you're
you shouldn't be playing in the wba yeah
i think all the top players um feel that
way
you know and if you don't feel like you
should be on that mountain or
be holding a trophy
but to me i think
more than anything
is about
championships
we talk about results
that's really the criteria right
you want to be
a champion and to me i think it's more
valuable to have more final finals mvps
than everybody not even regular seasons
and mvps like that's great you're
playing basketball in the regular season
but like finals mvps
so to me
i mean this is what i'm talking about
with the wnba there's there's people's
careers that started when they were 35.
cynthia cooper think about she would
have played in her primes cheryl miller
and there's all these if ands and butts
so yes as a competitor yeah do i want to
be holding that trophy but i don't want
to hold it if i don't deserve it you
know and so i think everybody mutually
like respects diana like diana is a
she's a baller
and i guess it's one of those things
where it's like how do you pick
the best superhero right they're all
good like yeah and in any given day i
think
that's how it is you know like how do
you how do you pick the best superhero
and you know i think everybody nobody's
disputing it as a player like we're not
like ah she got you know somebody
so-and-so got robbed like no you know
so it's one of those things where it's
like i respect the hell out of diana's
game and what she's done for the wba
mm-hmm
so
for you you talk about okay we need to
figure out what criteria is just in
general what should criteria be you said
championships
what else
because i feel this way about almost
everything we vote on mvp what is mvp is
it doing the most with a little is it
you know like what is but for this
conversation specifically the criteria
should be what that's a i mean taylor
listen that's the question
but i think once we all agree upon the
criteria i mean they come up with all
these statistics for
measuring defensive ratings and
offensive efficiency and all that stuff
like
pull that out you know like
figure out the
statisticians figure out a criteria i
don't know i don't think it's with the
necessarily with the naked eye because i
do think recently
if you look at
the amount of in-depth statistics
sometimes you don't realize like we
didn't realize
i was reading some the other day like
the largest plus minus in the last 10
years steph was like
4932 he leads the nba in the last 10
years and the biggest plus minus
differential yeah
like that's a stat we weren't keeping 12
years ago right but so do you realize
impact like is that what you measure
impact on so i think if we could develop
some type of criteria that would just
demonstrate
other than just putting the ball in the
basket how
great some of these players are like you
even talk about my teammate courtney
vander sloot
like
her on the court she is going to by far
lead the league
in assists like by far
right she's going to run away with it
but i think people don't realize the way
in which she manipulates the game or
hockey assist or like like even a stat
for stuff we realize his greatness
because we see him putting putting up
all these points
but like do you know how many times that
his teammates get looks because he's
just on the floor
like the toronto raptors were like
listen we're not gonna let you score but
he was like bet i'm gonna run around the
court
and he's not gonna watch it jordan poole
gonna get jump shot after jump shot off
of my hockey assist so i think it's
sometimes like impact
is far greater
you know if we have in-depth criteria so
we'll we'll see like i said um there's
no argument diana is an amazing player
she's led the league in scoring
numerous times she's got championships
like it's not like her resume
backs up you know backs up that debate
yeah and she's still fun to watch yeah
and she talks a lot which i i love when
people talk a lot that i'm like okay
that's the player i like where you would
be you're talking a [ __ ] on the court
yes absolutely so i'm with that but i
think if there's something just like
really cool too about like being the
people to be you know whether it's you
or diana and
i'll go ahead you were about to say
something
about kind of being the person to be
because i know nick saban once said once
you get to the top of the mountain you
become the mountain do you feel like you
kind of like you are the mountain right
now in the wnbc yeah i think sometimes
you have to watch her
you you have to guard your grill a
little bit because you know on a random
july
wednesday there's somebody that's coming
for your head because they grew up
watching you play yeah and it's like
hold on i'm having an off day right now
yeah so it's like that balance of
like
yeah
um and i love it listen i love it i love
it because i was that young kid that
didn't care whose name
who who was who i was going to go out
and dominate and i love that because i
think it continues to grow the game
absolutely and now i mean you open the
door cause you talked about nba 75 i
have to ask did you vote for dwight
dwight was not on my list really okay
defend your stance i don't really even
have a defense to be honest with you i
can say that
you know
here's the thing
i think it's also
the period at which it's being voted on
do you know what i mean
because if you're coming off of
you know his eight like would dame
damien lillard if 75 was in six years or
seven years would people remember
this period of time of dame lillard you
know so i also think it's like the
period of time that's being voted on
like did shaq deserve nba at 50 there's
people that debate that he didn't he was
surely going to be he got it very early
nba 50 and he surely is one of the 50th
greatest but it was like timing you know
and so i think that
right now with what i'm watching like i
voted for klay thompson to be honest
with you he was on my he was on my list
um well i would say i think circumstance
like yeah what is the criteria again we
go back to that what's the criteria and
we don't know i would say i think the
counter and what people probably will
say to that is well the point is it's
about the past
25 years so that is the time period i
got you but at the same time it's like
you also talk about length of resume
because to me luca you could argue for
luca right true sure
i mean
trey putting up numbers that have never
been done before in this era
of basketball
25 years ago like what is the criteria
and i think that's what we keep arguing
of if we leave it up to opinion yeah
because i and when you talk about clay
some people are like okay well we say
clay's like one of the greatest shooters
of all time but he's not in the like how
can he boot but he's won three
championships yeah like well how can he
be that but not in the 75 and it's like
it's this whole thing like lists in
general i'm like our list created for us
to debate i mean
because i'm starting to feel like that
is why they exist and i guess you know
it's fun to an extent it's all fun and
games so you're not on the list i mean
listen i grew up in chicagoland and it
was always whenever i would go back home
and get my hair done it would always be
is lebron gonna be better than jordan
and then that was the debate so yeah
listen
i still get suckered into it yeah uh
talk to me about your relationship with
usa basketball
i don't have one
um
yeah i don't have one um
i'm happy for them i when chelsea and
especially nafisa collier are my two
that i'm really close with
you know i don't have one and i think it
goes from the fact that
i think that when you evolve with time
that's when you're at your best and i
don't know if usa basketball has
continually evolved with time um
and then also i also believe that there
are so many times where
just
tell me and then i won't waste my time
like if that was the stipulations and so
i think it was very interesting
for me
personally
to
have a situation where
i went to a camp
i got a triple-double at the camp
was i think first or second in scoring
like it wasn't on the court yeah so if
it's me as an individual as a person
i'm spending time away from my daughter
to come and do these camps that i'm not
even being judged off of how i'm playing
what do you think you're judged off i
don't think i personally fit i don't
think gina wanted me on the team so i
think it's one of those things where
it's like cool like just tell me and
then don't you know
beat around the bush like just tell
people and so i think now we're reaching
a point where
players are becoming more empowered and
i've said this about the mba for a very
very very long time they started
becoming and i know the nba has been a
process but when the way that they
empower their players
where they have a voice they have a say
they talk to them they're honest with
things like the way in which they handle
nba
basketball
usa basketball like there's some people
it didn't matter
they were untouchable like you know what
i mean
and so i think that
based off of like i knew as soon as he
was named the coach again i was like oh
well
so he's gonna be interested why do you
think that is why do you think he did
not want candace parker on the team i
mean we he doesn't like me i don't like
i mean we don't like each other but i
think i am of the mindset and this is
where i think sometimes i get
misunderstood a little bit i'm of the
mindset that like i don't have to like
you to play with you i don't have to
like you to work with you
you know yeah and it's fine like it's
cool they they made their decision um i
laugh and joke that my kids will never
play usa basketball or usa sports at all
but listen it's a thing of the past
but i'm one of those people that's like
i get more angry at the people i love
getting hurt and what they did in neca
was
unbelievable yeah she deserved it's one
of those things where it's like
i'm more angry at that
because you have somebody that arguably
maybe
2016 but definitely she's the only mvp
of the league
you know what i mean she went and got i
think mvp of the world games and then
you leave her off the team
and so i think that there's you know
certain grace for certain people
and there's certain things that aren't
that you don't get grace yeah there's no
consistency listen
respect to connecticut connecticut
continues to crank out
player of the year after player of the
year right
um
at the same time though like when i was
there my four years at tennessee they
didn't win no national
championships talk it talk
they never beat us but yeah i don't know
like that might be a soft spot i don't
know
and he's like because
yeah because they couldn't get this
she's not gonna only hold on to when we
were there okay no i'm just kidding but
listen like
totally i just said because they called
back in 2000 to go for 2020 and i was
like
no like i'm not yeah it's like you're
not doing this did what you did it's
like i just can't i can't teach my
daughter lessons and tell her about you
know respect and treatment and
communication all this stuff and then go
back to that so i just i'm done i'm
happy i got two gold medals i appreciate
the experience um
and i wish them well honestly like i'm
so proud of chelsea and nafisa and you
know obviously sue and diana what they
did in terms of going to five olympics
and winning five medals like that's
super special and i think it's valuable
um
and it's important for usa to stay on
top yeah absolutely you said something
interesting which is that it hasn't
evolved over time can you just more so
elaborate on that what you want to see i
think in terms of just player and women
empowerment um you know there were so
many times where
and i get it they're you know
we play year-round
so i think there's so many times we're
now looking back especially after being
cut
that they have this expectation that you
just drop everything and just come and
play in your one break and i think the
evolution over time needs to like be
more about the player and the health you
know and i think
the way in which they do the men's like
kobe and lebron and d-wade didn't show
up to all the little mini camps
showing up yeah so listen i take that as
like
we got to make a whole lot more money to
have power and so that is my whole thing
in terms of leaving the game and i think
we're doing that especially with nio
with what the ncaa we're going to have
players that are now coming in with
checks that don't have to do that like i
don't i can make a choice not to do that
yeah and so i think with that is going
to become more power and similar to the
men's like you had a certain expectation
where it was like nah not doing that
you know and so i think it was for a
long time it's like
women dreamed of playing in the olympics
and they would do anything at any cost
so they almost own not owned you but
like but it was like they were pulling
the strings yes and now i think it's
gonna become at least i hope as an
evolution that it's gonna be become more
of a player's thing where it's gonna be
more player empowerment yeah no that's
great well i will say i hear a lot of
stories about just how fun like the
players lounge is at the olympics can
you tell me remember your favorite
players lounge olympic store i know you
guys play cards so this is one of my
favorite ones um
i believe it was in i have to close my
eyes and see which
players linger was i think it was in
london
boo ray was like huge oh are you losing
money remember that no i ain't but no
one listen i have it like that i had a
kid three like we was trying to send her
to private school like i wouldn't bet no
money
but i remember um jason kidd let diana
play for him one time like he got up to
go somewhere whatever and boo was just i
mean and kobe was just egging diana on
like just egging like oh nah like you
don't oh you're not gonna put like oh
you
lost all jake like all of his money this
had to be beijing because jason kid yeah
had to be beijing yeah
all of his money like literally got
booed it was hilarious and i just
remember watching kobe just stir the pot
the whole time you know how kobe does
yeah and then you know just in terms of
just the togetherness in beijing
going to the olympic village with the
men's team and realizing how much they
are just global superstars like i
remember going in london to
this club we were walking the club from
the hotel and just like watching people
drive by in cars and just like
how much they love usa basketball so it
was super special to be able to be a
part of that and then wait just to see
how much money did she lose like how
much of jason i'm breaking the code if i
say how much that i'm breaking the code
it was over i'll just say it was just
over it was over it was over and then
i'll say this and it all went to kobe um
well he got booed so he had to pay the
pot gotcha okay he had to pay the pot
but you know what i honestly this is the
funniest um
this is the funniest thing i remember
at the olympics this is in london
this is like you know
the guys are getting up there like we're
getting a little older like is this
going to be the last olympics for kobe
and for carmelo and you know for those
guys and i remember the women's
basketball team we practiced every day
so like we played we practiced the men
only showed up and played they didn't go
to shoot around and whatever so we're
complaining because we're about to play
our third game in six days and we're
there about to be you know at practice
whatever we get there kobe is in a full
sweat
an absolute full sweat
got there did his shooting work out and
was leaving
and i just remember just being like
that's why he's one of the best to ever
play is because he's there when he
doesn't have to be before our practice
you know and so it was just so special
to be able to see how these guys work
like
at the weightlifting you know what i
mean things like that and so i think
those are the relationships when you're
on those trips that you're able to
establish and d-wade same thing like i
became mad cool with him because of you
know because of the olympics no i love
that story just seeing like
the kobe dedication that you hear tales
of for so long actually seeing it right
in front of you unbelievable that he is
always putting in that work and he talks
so much can i can i say [ __ ]
he talks so much [ __ ] i had just met his
daughter i told a story all the time
literally in beijing in the hotel
vanessa and the girls had just got there
went up hey to the kobe's like these
these are my two daughters this is nanny
and gigi i'm like cool reach over hey
hey he's like yeah she's gonna break all
your records
i was like ain't this like the most kobe
thing i'm like she can i say hi to the
little girl you know
so he was just always super competitive
at whatever yeah and stirred the pot and
so
it was cool to see like the inner
workings of just how things
how what makes
people so great you know and so
competitive yeah and i mean you know we
all know about just the beautiful
relationship that exists between you and
kobe also vanessa his entire family i
remember you talking about
how kobe kind of taught you about keep
shooting like even if
you're missing and we know he knew how
to do that he kept shooting yeah he kept
shooting can you just kind of expand on
what he taught you about you know not
stopping even if maybe things aren't
aren't going your way
it's interesting because i remember you
know everybody was just like oh my gosh
how do you hit the game winner how do
you hit the game winner he was like six
of 27 from the field and then came down
and knocked down the game winner
and i remember i just could not wait to
ask like how do you how do you know
you're going to hit the game winner yeah
and
you know i remember him just talking
about how
i've put in too much work like the
percentages are in my favor that the
next one has to go in and that's how he
thought how he thinks like honestly it
was unbelievable to watch and then
to be able to work out with him and just
to see the attention of detail and how
much work and energy that he put into
every move
you see why
it was the confidence to shoot yeah and
it's not the bum you know in terms of
like yeah i believe in myself
it's like he actually put in the work to
be able to have that
to hang his hat on you know and i think
it was just unbelievable for me because
i nobody likes missing but sometimes i
shy away from that because i'm not
hitting or like today's not my day like
i'm not feeling it today or whatever and
it's like no
like you put the work in
like the next one has to go in yeah
and i wonder you know do you feel like
confidence is a thing that you work on
i think confidence is what's developed
you know those people it's like funny
because my brother and i joke about this
like his oldest and layla are very
similar where they have like this
confidence where you're like
but like where did you get this from
because you haven't you don't know that
you don't and they'll confidently tell
you a fact and you'll be like
that ain't true like but do you believe
it you know yeah so there's that they
believe because they believed it there's
like that confidence which i think is
very special and it's like you're born
that way and then there's confidence
that's developed through repetition
and i learned that from watching my
brother i learned that obviously from
watching kobe but i think it it comes in
the adversity
you know everybody can be competent when
you're shooting 10 for 12
shooting 10 for 15 but i think it's it's
interesting to kind of have a front row
seat to all these amazing players and
all these amazing shooters and you
realize why they're able to hit the
shots they hit like
steph reggie have the interview
coming out about the three
and steph said
i value this
this award or this recognition after
being all-time three-point leader
because of all the shots i've put up
like he's put up and worked hard and
just refined his craft to be able to
shoot like that like
on my team allie quigley one of the best
shooters i've ever known in my entire
life diana taurasi when i played
overseas with her like we act like this
is just like oh you're born that way and
yeah they're born with a higher level of
skill but they put in the time to like
give me some of it yeah they put in the
time to refine it and it it's probably
you know it's
it's a lot of time yeah you know and so
it's like there's a lot of people that
want to do that but then when it comes
time to doing it they don't yeah you
know it's a bit of a tangent one of my
favorite things about you is do it one
of my favorite things about you is
almost all of your stories include your
daughter
it's my baby yeah like she is just such
a centerpiece like two-year world
and you said a quote that like i always
remember you said
she sacrifices her mom
so that i can live my dream
can you tell me what you meant by that
yes um
layla is and i know i'm partial but
she's just such a special soul like we
always joke she tells the story about
how like you know i'll tell her bedtime
stories and sometimes she'll tell me
like a story and it's like her
confidence is probably made up you know
and she sits there and she's like there
was these two other kids and they were
like trying to be your kid and i was
like no and i like pushed him out the
way and then i was your kid and that was
you know that's how we came to be and i
really honestly feel like she seriously
chose me and i'm so grateful that she
did because she just
is such an amazing individual amazing
soul
so understanding so empathetic so
positive
i taught her none of this like that is
all her um
and i think that
i grew up with my mom at every single
thing that i did
and it tears me to shreds when i can't
be there and support her in the way that
i want to
um
but it's like her
realization of things like her
understanding even from a very young age
of like
i want you to be great like i i want you
to like live your dreams like i'm cool
you know
and i think in doing that obviously it's
made us closer but i think it's also
just
i think it's also just put into
perspective of like i am whole and i'm
better for her when i'm
happy and living my dreams and doing
what i want now yes there are drawbacks
and setbacks and things like that but
like
i'm better i'm a better mom to her
because i'm able to do what i love every
day
and you know so much of her you know
being okay with you doing that is a
credit to how loved and secure and
special you make her feel so she's like
well i know you can do that because you
always i'm first
you know even though i'm going to do
this yeah she has to know that she has
to know that um i want to include her in
everything possible um i want to
show her
you know on my worst days there's so
many times where
when she was little especially
i didn't want to get out of bed and go
to practice or i didn't want to get on a
flight and go overseas or i didn't want
whatever and i would say like i got out
of bed for you today you know and
we got into a little
disagreement this is a couple weeks ago
and she came over to me and was like i
did my homework for you today
you know
and so it's like
hey
i just
i love her and you know we're both a
work in progress but it's just so great
to be able to have somebody that like
understands you and just like i
genuinely like
love being around her like she's my
little homie yeah you know i have a lot
of friends who are moms and something
that a lot of them talk about is you
know obviously you are so incredibly
excited when you know you're going to
have a kid but there also is like this
fear oh yeah about how your life is
going to change about how good of a
parent you'll be
and you know something i think about
sometimes with having kids is i'm like
how is this going to affect work
and what am i going to do if it affects
work so i just wonder like was that a
fear for you like having this kid will
this change my basketball career will i
be as good like and did that affect
maybe deciding to have another kid or
not having another kid like what was
that for you
well first i've always dreamed of being
a mom i was the kid at 12 still playing
with dolls like i had all my kids names
picked out i babysat in college like i
wanted to be a mom um
and i realized that there was the
balance and i think i would really argue
with anybody that loved basketball more
than i did especially when i had laila
than me um i loved basketball more than
anything you know and um
it was one of those adjustments but i
think it's kind of
i put things in place where i'm present
wherever i'm at and i learned that from
coach summit i watched her seamlessly
make everybody that she was with feel
like they were the only person in the
entire world
and that was what mattered because at
that moment it does you just have to
know yes you are going to feel guilty
there are going to be days that are very
hard where you feel guilty about
something you can't do at work or
something that you can't do at home
but also very valuable lesson no is a
sentence and i think as women sometimes
like we don't confidently say no it's no
well i just i sometimes know is a
sentence and i think you have to be be
okay with that
balancing a career just as with
basketball there's ups and downs there's
things that go your way there's some
days where you feel hyper motivated and
some days where it's a grind to get out
of bed
just at work you can love what you do
but there's days that are difficult and
same thing with motherhood same thing
with career
it it does take some adjusting but at
the same time it's like the rewards i
mean are
unbelievable yeah especially if you have
a village like i've been fortunate
enough to have where my family my
friends they all help there was a time
where i couldn't show up to layla's
student of the month award two years ago
my entire friend group
went balloons i was on facetime you know
so i think there's other ways to show
your kids that they matter
school taking her to school is
non-negotiable i block out my time
because that's when you get the most tea
from you know she's a little yeah so
what's going on you get the most tea but
also the most authentic raw
conversations so i just think that those
moments are so important to me um to be
able to be present for those but also
just like the balancing act
that women play especially people like
you people like allison felix you guys
do so much
in addition to being moms and i just
don't know if people really understand
like the world that exists within all of
your worlds i mean can you speak to that
how are you all able to do that
well first i think being a mom you
become like you get super powers you
know it's like you get this adrenaline
like i was worried about sleep and
you know all this stuff and figuring out
maneuvering and i was a big couch potato
when i came home from practice you know
and it's like all of a sudden you get
this like mom strength you know
um
but i think also you start recognizing
that
you can really be a catalyst for like
changing that narrative because
there's so many times where i'm out on
the road and people ask me like where is
your kid who's taking care of her where
is she at right now but they don't ask
lebron those questions yeah and now
we're seeing more so with the effort of
paternity leave and
and things like that of how important it
is to have two parents
you know and to have two parents that
are involved and that are sharing
responsibility and
you know
it is a challenge to juggle doctor's
appointments and dentists and doing all
that stuff and you know i'm fortunate
enough to have a lot of help
i think it's all moms i don't think it's
just
you know athletes and i think that's the
thing that we need to talk about more is
there's a lot of people that aren't in
the spotlight that are doing this on a
daily basis
that can't bring their kids to the track
or to the basketball court yeah and so i
think it's about continuing to have
those conversations about like the need
for
you know second parent to step up and
you know to take some responsibility and
to understand how important their role
is yeah i mean being a mom i feel like
just from looking at my mom looking at
moms i know it is the most difficult job
on earth there's this book you should
read it's called invisible women and she
just talks about how all of this like it
is work but it's just unpaid work but
the way that we paint moms that maybe
can't go to work because they're raising
kids or whatever make it seem as though
they aren't doing something but they're
actually doing everything you know so i
think that's really important and kudos
to you i mean you
play basketball you do all these events
you do tnt it's just a lot going on so i
just think it's amazing and it is
something that i look to as well um
before we go those big mtnt i have to
ask what is the key to beating shaq in
an argument because i think that you're
undefeated at the moment i appreciate it
um
you know honestly it's so funny to me
because on air it's like
second to what happens in the green room
oh yeah i know we're watching television
and he just has this like hot take and
me and d wade are like
do you want to engage today or do you
want me to like how do you want to do it
listen the dude is amazing um
it's been fun to see more so these
players that i idolize for their stats
and for their ability to dominate now as
people
and um
you know i think it's just so funny to
see a facetime and layla's like is that
uncle shaq and i'm like yes and then she
can't wait to go back to the studio for
to play uno because he like destroyed
her and uno i'm like could you let her i
can like see shaq and you let her win
for some reason like why are you making
her draw 24 cards like what is going on
and he's like the whole time like
take that i'm like she's six like can
you
see like she was like seven or eight at
the time like what is going on but yeah
yeah i mean no you keep playing on cause
i'm like oh candy's about to ken is
about to push you gotta come with facts
i have brothers you gotta come with
facts if you don't come with facts then
you're not gonna win
all right two more for you uh i talked
to paige beckers yesterday i was
interviewing her about her gatorade deal
you know she's really taking advantage
of nil and i asked her if she had a
question for you and she just wanted to
know how you deal with media meaning do
you ignore the bad stuff do you read the
bad stuff like how do you
handle the spotlight
well first i think
if you're authentic
and genuine
then i think that
you're going to continue to be okay
you know if you are authentically okay
with
criticism that for me fuels me
so you almost have to individually know
how you're wired you know to me it was
i just remember reading you know after i
tore my acl like oh this this and this
and it's like i probably shouldn't have
but i worked my way back and got back in
five months after acl like i just used
that as like fuel totally so i need that
criticism um
but honestly i think it's just
it's one of those things where you have
to develop those boundaries and
you know in what you will listen to and
i was always taught that if you're your
biggest critic then nobody can out
criticize you
you know and so i think you know this is
a tough age you know where it's you're
very fortunate to be able to
you know do the things that they do and
pages
is definitely um
on top of her game but also
being able to have the advantage of
establishing what she wants to do as a
professional now yeah you know
establishing relationships i would say
to continue to establish those
relationships even with media members
because i think it's important you know
it's important to establish and have
those
type of people that you can call and
and talk to and and meet on a human
level yeah no i love that love watching
paige love watching leah boston like i
just this is this is going to be a fun
year for sure all right last thing for
you when i was watching some of your
interviews you do something that i am
now going to steal uh-oh when you drink
wine like important wine you save the
cork
and you write like who was there what
was talked about whatever the case case
may be
so of all the quarks that you've saved
which cork means the most oh my goodness
okay so
everybody here knows that i'm the
biggest jay-z fan
that there is yeah
um
so the night i i put in the universe
that i was going to meet jay-z and i
didn't want to meet him on some like
like take a picture
i wanted to meet him on some like
business stuff you know and so i had the
opportunity
um to sit down with him at his office
and talk to him for 45 minutes to an
hour i'm not counting but it was 57
minutes but in 20 seconds 26 seconds
and that night and my friends came over
and we toasted like we always talk about
to the empire like to building to
lifting each other up and i'm just so
grateful to have
a friend group that really like
you know uplifts me and embraces me and
we celebrate each other's wins as if
they're our own
um
and so yeah i wrote on that cork
you know the empire to life to cheers
and it's just like that one kind of sets
itself apart yeah just because it's
really special and what it embodies and
you know i just have so much respect for
jay and what he's accomplished and i
think the similarities of
being a rapper and what people expected
and anticipated and the deals that
weren't brought to you because you were
a rapper and wouldn't put on a suit and
now it's like with women's basketball
like
are we capable of being investors are we
capable of having a seat at the table
you know those are all questions right
now and i definitely want to
continue to move it forward and not
allow that to be a question anymore yeah
well you are so multi-hyphenate
you do it all so i i have no doubt you
can we'll continue to do that and hey i
know you know you have a lyric and a
wu-tang song you need a you need a jay-z
you need a jay-z lyric that's what's
good that's what's coming next but no i
i truly enjoy this i feel like i mean i
see you all the time i feel like i
learned so much more about you so 1992.
i was oh my gosh
hey 30 next year baby i'm coming for you
it's an enlightenment oh i'm ready i
can't wait 30 is better than 20. and i
know i always look forward to it like a
daisy song like
you know 40s new 30 i'm so it really is
no it really i feel like you know
yourself yeah and like just you're more
self-aware things are established around
you you can really like enjoy literally
okay with saying no and you're okay with
being you yes i'm looking forward to it
i am looking forward to it
so much
and i feel like now i have to say we had
to end this like to the empire i like
that hashtag to the empire let's go
thank you candice i appreciate
[Music]
you